all right another lunch by myself oh  damn I was gonna catch up on Instagram  this seat taken  oh yeah Oh it'll be fine maybe I can  still scroll through no she's looking at  me okay good that's all you got come on  Elliot you've read books on this no it's  pretty good for me good for me that  doesn't even make sense did I hit a  leprechaun on the way to work or  something  did you watch Game of Thrones I'm saying  oh no I get HBO but I did see Antiques  Roadshow you know it's more amazing than  dragons an extremely rare Navajo Chiefs  blanket worth half a million dollars  yeah find one of those on Game of  Thrones Instagram here I come well back  to the grind yeah yeah go get them tiger  go get him tiger what I've never said  that before in my entire life but it was  worth it alone at last  eating alone is the absolute best I  think she called me Ethan the other day  it's Elliott Elliott  you